So the upshot of the logical protection domain is the ability to extend SPIN
to include operating system services and make that all part of the same
hardware address space, so no border
crossing between the services or the mechanisms
provided by SPIN. So here is one example where all these system services are
implemented as protection domain and using create, resolve and
combine. We've created all these services as logical extensions
of SPIN. Here is another extension living on top
of the same hardware, concurrently with the first
extension. And as you see, each of these mounds represent
a completely different operating system. And each
of these mounds may have their own
subsystems for the same functionality. For instance,
this process uses memory manager two. This
process uses memory manager one. Both of
them implement the same functionality. But very
differently, hopefully, to cater to the needs
of the applications that need those services.
But they may also have common
subsystems. For example, the network protocol stack,
may be shared by both extensions that live on top the same hardware framework.